firstly what is your name and what award
we got for today hi my name is Angela
Rimmer and I was up for sports
contribution in the community excellent
so can you tell us what you've done in
order to achieve your wall today and I
started some back to netball sessions in
the in the local community of Timoth and
they were very successful so successful
we ended up forming Timoth thunderbirds
netball club and now we compete in the
winter league in both Exeter and torbay
leagues can you describe who has been
involved in your project age ranges
numbers yeah well we've welcomed over a
hundred people I heard women back to
netball now aged 15 to 64 and a lot of
the girls really didn't feel that they
were able didn't have the confidence to
play netball some of them were even told
they were too old to play and really we
welcome to everybody back to netball and
they've just loved it and it's become
more and more popular word got round and
yeah that's kind of how we became so
successful really can you describe what
some of the sessions might look like oh
yeah they're really good fun and the
emphasis it t-birds is really all about
having fun and helping to improve
everybody's confidence really and it's
it's a very sociable sport and it's
really all about having fun rather than
winning